it's finally us would buy the equipment
to be told what we can do within yeah
yes it's fun oh that's the reason for
recovering anyway oh we come yeah yes so
I'm staying nothing yeah that's not a
small time okay well tell o'clock ladies
and gentlemen good morning welcome to
the planning policy subcommittee so I
don't as we have a quite a number of us
here I will go through the emergency
evacuation procedure in the event of
fire or other emergencies please exit
the building in an orderly manner to the
assembly point which is located in the
car park parallel to the building the
fire exit in this room is indicated by
the green fire sign exit please do not
delay the evacuation by collecting any
belongings do not use the lift the
premises must not be reentered until the
fire brigade have good milk
here please notice against the law to
smoke in these premises please know this
meeting is being audio recorded maybe
you're right right moving on apologies
for absence thank you number was
attending Casas new port stanley and
ward thank you item number three is the
minutes of the planning policy
subcommittee held on the twenty-second
of june which as you've all seen
previously um can I ask I mean we did
raise at various meetings prior to that
a lot of section which referred to
holding of regular meetings when we said
monthly meetings but most of that is
history now so apart from that amendment
which we have registered previously
while you approve the minutes of the
22nd of June okay right moving on to
item number five the new local plan
early engagement workshop sorry sorry
declarations of interest oi any
declarations of interest is none now
moving on to item number five then the
new local plan early engagement workshop
and survey am i passing out here natalie
and so as you would all be aware we
under to leave the workshops and over
the summer and pour into the autumn as
well not a supplementary I survey you
would all have receive the concentration
statement that had been paired which has
brought together all of those and the
main issues that were raised and our
response to those and I don't really
have a lot of sound is anyone
any questions like the thing that's the
first the first point we've only seen or
had the opportunity to read the report
see the report is there any areas some
members that they wish in to enlighten
or question or expand on it's only other
place you want to raise Natalie I mean
in a more gentle turn we've seen a
report is there is there things you've
learned from from this opportunity
things you guys do differently should we
go down this road again or we will
hopefully go down this road again I
think it has been a youthful experience
for us and following the adoption of the
the fci back in July obviously we've
gone down to the to the parish level we
did find it challenging to engage with
some of their paraschiv actually
arranging meetings which in some
circumstances we haven't been able to
give as much awareness of workshops as
we would have liked we also had some
issues issues towards the back end of
the programme of the workshops in
actually programming those workshops in
before the end of the survey which
resulted in deserve have been extended
to enable people to put forward any
additional comments that make habits
they were unable to attend so they were
there were challenges and we may
consider whether it's right going down
to to that level where we need when we
need border workshops just into the main
towns and villages well then trying to
go to every single
every time how're you say broad it how
do you mean broader for example going to
have rarely hockley ruptured and maybe
then the main villages as well an
inviting people from outside the area to
those villages rather than trying to go
to evil some individual perishing it's
about right we're open to well we've got
a couple of people that like to to speak
here so let's start off with jump that's
okay you very first time and I'm glad
you said let's let's talk about
learnings because that's exactly what I
jotted down I I do have and have had
criticism of the way we did as you know
and I would refer to it completely
complied with our statement of community
involvement but he didn't that I noting
the report by saying that it isn't a
statutory consultation so maybe there
for a reason but I am I am looking for
future consultations to be completely to
the letter of that I agree can I just
you know could you possibly clarify
where you don't think you met be
starting a comedian yeah well I don't
believe that the monitoring was was
appropriate as you know when I put that
in writing to you when it talks about
regular monitoring I don't see monthly
monitoring you know in a six to
eight-week period as as appropriate I
think monitoring needs to be earlier
also our and I was going to go on to
this later but our statement of
community involvement specifically added
the issue of leafletting which was
something that this subcommittee wished
wish to see and if any wasn't and the
situation is that in our informal
meetings or we've certainly
together acknowledged that leave losing
is something we want to see in the
future and i know you and i Mr swearing
accounts as bearing spoke at the Olay
day and sponsored the the idea of a
20,000 pound budget each year that there
are consultations to to achieve that
having said that as you probably know I
have regular meetings now with bmd and
he didn't seem to share our i'm going to
say our our support of obliging
commenting that most councils now trying
to get rid of it and he prophet the idea
that you know engagement on on
consultations should should be a broadly
they're trying media base we had a
debate on that i think i've managed
through talking about my experience of
leafletting and elections and turnout
and so forth but leafletting did have
value so you know I stand by what we
said it is in our statement of community
involvement and I would expect it to be
you know fully performed in that respect
when we go to the issues and options
consultations and those in in future I
would also agree completely that we I
don't think I was in a position
individually to influence his parish to
parish method we use that certainly was
already underway before i was on the
planning policy subcommittee so i
couldn't the influence that but i think
on reflection and i would prefer like
you okay its subsequent but i would have
preferred to say district wide
consultation because we are talking
about spatial strategy for a district
not a spatial strategy for individual
parishes which of course have their own
opportunities through their parish plans
if that's how they
tend to use on one particular
neighborhood plan to actually execute
such a view and contribute to the local
plan so I'm one of the view that a
district wide consultation is
appropriate most appropriate for a
district spatial strategy I think we
have the opportunity to consider other
options like north essex has suddenly
come out with which I didn't know who's
coming garden communities for instance
and that's that's something that you
know we we should have already talked
about if we knew about it and I'm sure
we did I did but that's not the point
and I'd like to see that obviously come
forward in our issues and options
because you know it is an option that
should be explored with our residents
and on a kind of a final note I'm
finding it difficult to agree to the
recommendations because it talks about
the content being agreed and there are
some responses to the content which I
actually don't agree with so I can't
support the recommendation unless it
moves towards noted because I can't
agree to it because I don't agree with
everything has been responded I can't
disagree with what presidents have said
suming it's accurate but I'm not sure I
agree with everything was said in
response Thank You Jen okay thank you
thank you making up some of your points
John I think I've harped on about this
before I think it was unfortunate that
Christine lines with her experience was
should we say instrumental in organizing
what netting lee and eivin dam had to
pick up in no longer and aside from from
their point of view they didn't have a
benchmark to work to to start with
whereas crispy noise didn't know what
she had done in the past and what was
going to happen and what wasn't in
happen I think your point you've made is
that it was a non statutory requirement
so you
it was a learning curve for assault from
my observations on the few that i went
to feel 4.56 i went to i do question how
we're going to get anybody to engage for
this if I can't get local town and
parish councillors to come and show any
interest in it and they didn't know
about it and they did know the
implications of what we were trying to
do i do question how we can get the vast
majority of residents to support the
issue but there as you as your where
John we have asked the council for a
budget to to me what we think is is the
way ahead and we'll have to wait and see
if they've got the money in there in the
budget to do it but it will be a large
sum of money for a number of years on of
almost annual basis how do you don't
question be madly and how do you account
for the level of attendance on
reparative trading particularly and also
the techniques that you use for
surveying male shotting were they were
they advanced techniques or where they
just appeared to me as as the survey was
very basic it was just an open-ended
form I think a lot of residents will put
off by that I know now that a lot of the
surveys are coming out or a bit more
structured yeah and also how will we
track in responses to surveying because
you know there's a lot of them
techniques there where we can see if
someone's open the email if they've you
know clicked on a link you know was that
kind of technique used it when we use in
male shot in
particularly electronic mail shot into
people and okay I'll take you all your
first point about the attendance of the
workshops and so in the report we have
clearly set out how many people we've
got on our mailing it to me directly
notified of these of the workshops and
as you can see in a number particularly
hullbridge I think Riley there there's
quite a few residents that honor my
English you weren't directly notified or
that I mean I can't say why oh I
couldn't couldn't attend or didn't want
to attend I mean particularly there the
evening workshop there was there a blood
donation session going on that we didn't
know about so that might have had an
influence in terms of people are to be
able to get access to me and to venue
lilia wrap there were also other issues
with some of the workshops and like I
said we had trouble engaging with some
para trees so we couldn't give as much
magnification workshops as you would
have liked so there are there are some
factors which could have influenced
attendance also it could be couldn't be
a kind of people weren't generally
interested in in what the workshops are
about because we didn't have anything
fun to look at we weren't actually
consulting on a specific proposal so
that may have also influenced and
influence the workshops that's just
that's just mine that's just my opinion
non-spatial i think i think i'll come
back to the point though James if we
cannot get our own town and parish
councillors to come along to any bean
and they all they were all fully aware
of it and the same Riley not all the
town councillors came along to the event
I do you did not know but not all over
you did but how that number I was
with other counselors and the worst
public yeah I can't afford public yeah
back and how many cases we got ready say
okay so thankful go good we've had a
response from sean's burn em to a town
council or something along the lines of
Old Town Council's not interested in the
plan was a yes ever Wendy and so on that
point and that was um I believe as a
result we more from the Clark saying
that we offered the the town council to
be bit more involved in the process and
unfortunately they the town council had
a meeting and they decided they didn't
want to be fully on board with thee with
the workshop that's not why well that's
that's not for us to our okay that's for
you to take up with the really terrible
by the park they'd been disgusted at the
Town Council unfortunately you want to
fully involved in I will check with the
park yeah that is that's an issue an
internal issue we can the district nami
response was instead to christian and
that's the second point sorry yes and
surveys aight aight i take your point
that they were it was very brief but
again we didn't have anything specific
for people to actually comment on
whereas in in later stages were
virtually court document they do tend to
be more structured as this was an
informal non-statutory consultation and
it's off the back of the workshops or it
had a lot of them different ideas and
opinions coming through a man we had
restructured the surveys that was open
as possible he sit down with a
thoughtful and gave guidance or what and
come out of the workshops already so as
a native if people wanted to have a look
at the workshop nice they include and if
they had anything else to add and they
they could do that if they chose to and
as as you'll see from the consultation
statement we had number of people that
didn't decide to add additional comment
or repeat comments strengthen what
already been forward to us but some
people just used it as a means to be put
on our mailing list and they they didn't
have anything specific to add at that
time but they were letting us know that
they wanted to be involved in few pages
and what about my last point back how we
felt amazing us tracking and we don't do
anything specific at the moment and I'm
assuming we would have I believe with
the new IT that's coming in right in our
counsel award so the new IT that's
coming in if people tap on it is
registered straightaway whether they
respond or not but they have opened it
and that I understand is the new IT
system that is coming in and that would
be part of the package when he comes in
client just come in just on this just a
brief for other things that I've I
specifically asked is that was a new IT
actually coming into into being which
should be that long one hopes as soon as
the whole concept is if it is a survey
up there and there's an information on
that survey the moment they touch that
link that's registered so it's
registered as them hadn't shown interest
now you know we're having to count our
apathy look apathy through electorate as
well which is which is big problem but I
think the most important thing is where
we have tried to get it out there and
people have actually tapped on that link
so they can actually see it at least we
know that it's been viewed it's been
looked at there may be no response they
may look at it and decide not to respond
to it in any way shape or form they may
not
why but at least we know that they've
seen it we've got a count of those
people who have had a visual room to
know this existed but and then we have
taken forward to see where he goes make
believe you're yeah it's just a just to
come back on point just just for my
benefit I haven't sort of experience
some of the issues that come to the
Mason is raised at the SC I just want to
explore bit more about what you meant
about monitoring with the SC I the sei
if you if you've looked at a particular
paragraph in there that we all crafted
was cynically I mean I can't quote it
verbatim scenario in front of me but the
base is obvious the intentional bit and
the actual words of it are there shall
be regular monitoring during the course
of any consultation now to me we can we
can sit here and we can argue like
lawyers about what regular means regular
is the word that's in the dictionary
english dictionary got a legal
disclaimer although I think a legal
dictionary will probably say the same so
regular to me means that it's got to be
an appropriate theory disappear during
the during the whole period of the
consultation to me to me that means if
it's an 8-week consultation I can't see
any reason why it can't be done weekly
if somebody wants to argue with me it
should be done for a Niley we could talk
about it but any any longer than that it
doesn't give you the intention of the
addition and the clarification and the
statement made in the SDI is to ensure
that during a consultation if it's not
going so well we can find out what
engagements aren't going so well to
investigate why we may not be capture
that data or investigating wise not
happening considering whether or not
there are other channels of engagement
that we need to to adopt on the other
hand if it's showing that we're doing
extremely well then we we get an
assurance and a comfort that we've
actually organized it properly that I
hug Jim as you were you know one of the
few people that were here when that was
a breed would you agree with I'm sorry
change once you agree that's what we and
we also emphasized the need to reach
hard-to-reach groups I think the problem
is I would raise the earlier you are you
saying earlier also looking that way I
was included in love because that was my
biggest concern that we won and this is
everyone will know you know this online
assumption everyone these days will
respond to you in that way clearly by
the numbers of responded it doesn't work
anyway and but we're not actually
getting the information to the people
that may respond to us and and do need
to know what is happening and out of
that 20,000 yet it's a large sum of
money but if it does the trick and we
get even you know five more people
respond it's quite a percentage on the
response but I think this is the
question I would ask and I'm sure
somebody else will ask what do what
level do you consider is a successful
response well that's it not first
meeting is it well it is if joy it is if
John says we are monitoring over so your
fault nightly basis for ultimately what
what what level do we regard five
percent ten percent to example Oh take
time to mentor yes because you guys guys
can we just you've actually address so
yeah no no no I film then I'm about to
respond yeah but of course I mean I
spent quite a bit of
professionally he be involved in
customer service satisfaction surveys
consultations etc and I could shot off
some figures of attainment and that you
know were considered to be appropriate
to say that that was you know a
statistically relevant response to a
customer-service satisfaction in the
financial services industry however I
don't think I should do that because I
think it's incumbent on us as a council
to to find out and then it's probably
through desktop research just what the
norms are today for the sort of channels
we're using and I don't think it's
impossible to do that I think if i sat
down with google and the various
channels i would probably just put in a
single search and come up with probably
four or five a very relevant pages all
we research data particularly from the
political political spectrum and the
commercial spectrum to indicate what we
should work should be seen throw that
one to you because I think they're going
to come into your your sphere I mean I
mean interesting looking at the
consultation statement we had a total of
just just to look at the paragraph 2.3
we had a total of seven thousand and
thirteen direct form notification sent
out publicizing the workshop and we had
a total of 293 residents and businesses
attend which I think shows that you know
the difficulty that and the challenge
that we have which is you know four
percent attending which is you know
which you know although we had
businesses and residents attend it's a
low figure you know and I don't think
that is you know systematic just
Rochford from my experience you know
that that unless it's a a very direct
issue for people and obviously at later
stages when you have issues and options
or proposals you know there's something
of substance that people
you know sort of look at so you do tend
to get more responses the southland area
action south and what should airport
ayer action plan you know that that had
stages where it did get a lot of
responses because it was a issue and the
timings and the stage of production of
the document meant that more people
wanted to get involved because the issue
was very real to them at that time I
guess having early engagement process at
the moment it's very open-ended and
you'd want it to be open-ended because
you don't want to direct people too much
you want to say okay this is what's out
there you know give us your views all
views because you don't want to feel
like you're directing people to certain
it so it is more open ended at this
stage of the process and it and it will
become more focused and in relation to
surveys and questionnaires you know they
can come become more focused as you move
down the process in relation to the
monitoring process yes I guess if you
have a 68 week you know consultation
process as part of an issues and options
preferred options submission you know
version of a planning document you you
have opportunity to engage people in
specific ways which the SC I will
outline how you monitoring how you
monitor that during that process if
there are workshops then you know it's
having that timing and ability to change
those matters as you move through that
process from my experience you do tend
for planning consultations to get all
the consultations in at the last moment
you have you have nothing for the eight
weeks as far as representations coming
in and then you have if not all your
representations coming in on the last
few days so during that monitoring
process it's very difficult to say oh
you know we're not getting those
representations in and we need to do
something as far as that's concerned
because most of your representations do
tend to come in on the day of the
clothes of the cons
patient it's just the way it seems to
work but I agree that you know during
the consultation process if if we do not
seem to be getting the levels of
attendance for workshops or other
meetings that we're we're organizing
then you know there is some merit in in
reviewing that throughout the process to
see to see what's possible but equally
from my experience it is very difficult
to get people to engage in planning
consultations and the planning process
as such unless you know it is an emotive
issue or you are at a stage where you
have specific proposals out there do you
want to come back John then I'll move on
to something else yeah I do right I
don't wish to something unless it's not
an argument no no it's not a you know
Cora point/counterpoint I understand
what you say we just have to you know be
a learning organization and learners as
much as we can as quickly as possible to
get the best the best sort of results
for our understanding of what residents
see is what they like to see a lot like
to see to inform the process in terms of
engagement I think there's one one
particular issue that I don't know how
to solve and it's the same with every
consultation we do because we produce a
technical document because we have to
produce a technical document because
those are the terms of the statutory
engagement however those things are
terribly difficult to engage with unless
you happen to be a very interest being
and dedicated person and the I've always
said said to to any officer
contemplating a consultation I'd say yes
of course you've got to excite me the
air quality one you know you put in this
exam with the planning watsonia there
are parallels is is to say fine you know
produce your statutory compliant produce
it in the form of the language it has
structure it has to be and then I say
but but if you could put something on
top of that but honestly was a an honest
representation price if of you know a
bit like the old executive summary
precis whatever that is where you're
going to find the level engagement now
if you do something like that and pull
out the points that are particularly
likely to be of interest to resonance
you can then redirect them with a
hyperlink if they happen to be online or
not as the case may be to the particular
part of the document they want to read
though so yeah I mean I can see okay so
you know you're coming from join I'm and
I can but I think having said that who's
good you know we could be criticized
subsequently for not bringing out the
most pertinent point because that point
that we haven't all out is important to
somebody and when we've moved in
automotive about here yeah I mean it's a
good idea to do something like that we
used to do that kind of approach at cell
phone I mean obviously as you stressed
it's a technical it's a statue document
and statutory consultation process they
have to comment on the statutory
document so they cannot be commenting on
a summary of that that doesn't detail
the points in the way that it must be
made in a planning document but there is
there is some merit in having an
executive summary of the document so at
least people can get the flavor and
things and if they can direct them to
the main document than this very much I
mean it's if this is something perhaps
we could look at as a committee or
perhaps get for Council's approval that
if we want to produce this then it would
have to be the pricey for a breach
version or whatever you want to call it
be improved in principle by for council
war I don't know what level it would
have to be approved by that's something
we can sort out in the process if we
feel that's the way we we want to go but
well I'm conscious of is we could be
ugly nearly claimed that goes on all
evening about who wants what put into
what but what we could there's no as far
as I can see here if we
this is something that we may all
benefit from it might be advantageous
well then we can investigate it we just
we just make sure that we obviously
caveated it how are you here to say that
you know this is just for guidance only
and share be used for making
representations okay give me good is it
is it permitted at him and another now
go back to Chris and this pearl
initially when we were bringing out some
of the research we were doing and where
I was asking that the information that
was going out where we had hyperlinks
put in there this time which would
actually go to the full document so that
you could actually understand if you
wanted to read it you can go to
understand the backup explanation as to
how we're arriving at these things this
is one of the things that I asked the
lads did I think dan went through and
did quite a lot of this on the last
document that came out that he put
hyperlinks with regard to headings and
things so it gave a bit of bread for
depth you know rather than putting
everything in there you can actually see
the full explanation if you wanted to
but again I fully agree with the idea of
having something which is an easy brief
read then you've got the links that go
in there that can give you the depth of
what this is about we leave that you to
investigating makes and proposals for
exactly and if it's online then it can
have hyperlinks the document otherwise
you can have references to where you
find those main headings in the document
and it makes sense and it helps guide
people through as a map to the document
because they are technical so Chris you
were on wanted to speak of raising
questions mmm what up what would just
say and this is on the assumption that
everybody is online well I know that
this is the assumption
everybody's online what we're talking
and then we're talking at the moment so
we really gotta bump and expand their
you know I think the thing you could
probably do in future if you if you did
it if we can get the funding to do a
leaflet drop yeah obviously then you
could highlight these points and put a
point of contact in where people can
find this even if it meant either I
never so yeah but then I get back to the
workshops obviously way of where the
implications of most prevalent the
workshop and that is Roy parish was
greater than rayleigh on the basis that
and it was there was more people at the
parish workshop then there was a
brightly as there was only five a
trainee and uh now if there wasn't it
was there is no learning session as well
there was a great deal more at the
parish but there is no a section laura
is going to be you know empty in line
for four more housing tonight yeah but
where I'm saying Chris there were two
sessions in rayleigh and the afternoon
session was substantially better
supported than the evening one I don't
know why but it was and a whole bridge
and other places were very well
supported at other times so I think
there is an assumption of wire Roura
that should feel that they're going to
be the firing line and that's not been
decided yet but I go go with you your
comment that it was very well there was
interest to today's new interest right
okay so as I'm sorry I thought it was
well supported at Rory on the basis of
what is happening to Wes rightly and I
realize that the officers only went with
the census of 2010 information which I
was a bit disappointed for the fact that
the schools are well and truly up to the
max within one or two pupils and on
obvious a bit I think everyone that
attended these workshops but
disappointed in the fact that we did not
give out
great amount of availability and
localized issues on that report do you
have access to more current staff now I
would sense it says the 2011 sensor
section C is the last census that came
out I can't come in but because I wasn't
at the yes in terms of the education it
was the five-year plan which we were
basing it on which obviously is provided
by do realize that we're not focusing on
duty case yeah they are now I think
they're now releasing 10 year plans so
they should be taking into account
example road and the impact that would
have on on school capacity and as well
as well be long before we discuss the
impact on development of North Atlanta
road or west valley wave it outside and
that we didn't have a precise amount of
how many pupils what places they were
and the volume of whatever we be in the
way of the transport traffic goodness
knows what else so that would have been
I don't believe that would have been
better because then obviously raised a
few eyebrows at the beginning of the
session anything which it did because it
was felt that the council didn't have
any idea what was going on at this
present time which I think that is a
justified criticism paying service do we
have access to any more up-to-date
information that we could put into the
public domain in relation to school
places school places what Chris is just
me yeah I mean Patek but first as a
general comment on evidence base
obviously evidence base is developed
during preparation of a local plan or
any other planning document so you have
certain evidence that accumulates over
the time this is a early this is pre
issues an option stage this was early in
gay am on open issues so as we go
through the process I'm
there's more information the Essex
County Council will be able to give us
in relation to looking at capacities of
schools which will then feed into that
issues and options report okay all I was
trying to make an emphasis of it is that
if we need the public to involve get
involvement we need to give them an
up-to-date and precise account of what
he's in the community before we do
anything else and then they obviously
give them a better view and as my way of
looking for involvement with the
community is that how many counselors as
the council hold is there Emily
councillors which occurs on this council
39 right and have we had any information
from those 39 counselors from their
parishes or walls as to the you know and
they publicized enough had they gone
round and asked the community to get
involved with these projects I don't I
did I don't I kid I I went to I went to
my parish meeting and I said to them
you've gotta work we've got a workshop
going and try and get the leaflets out
which we did we printed another 400
leafing and we put those out and unless
the response we've got we've got a
better response than what we would do if
it was just a parish meeting unless
we're giving away chocolates or
something like that but I did actually
print on my arm printer leaflets to get
out there to the community other third
no I just wonder if there is something
we could look at with the counselors and
give them the leaflets and say deliver
these leaflets and see what the
responses with these I think we've
already covered this aspect Chris
because we lasted but they won't if
funding could be made available to go to
all the all the residents within the
district we've already asked for this to
go out for council so hopefully that
will nullify your the open sir do you
want to come back I was only just going
to reference what it says in
in the statement just that the workshops
were published publicized on a parish by
parish basis using the following methods
of notification and it says firewall
counselors and parish town councillors
so as a method so that's detailed okay
can I just tell when say on all we got
was 200 leaflets for the walls for the
pageant did we not go out through all of
the parishes in terms of what they did
in terms of newsletters newsletter here
fill one out opus and I remember council
i mentioned riverside or whatever its
local magazine was that there's river
private year so we have gotten no but
but generally it was yes I mean we are
adding tote we headed to your to your
the leaflets that we've given to us we
added another 200 and we managed to get
400m between three of us the most which
was quite good really but then then we
have learned from this nothing we say
we've said that if if we if the council
feels this is the way it's because wants
to go for subsequent meeting then there
is a cost involved all and that's what
they've got to decide whether they
wanted it one and if not then we have to
go back to plan B which is perhaps a
lesser system then some of us perhaps
feel that may be appropriate or Chris
sorry you you are some time to go Samuel
Alma okay in essence these personal
consultations was a fairly vague
open-ended water basically to what tell
us what you think issues are or pudding
tarts and it's not surprising that the
response of some from some of the houses
a very low in terms of
people attending people who invaded my
fingers counselors already know before
cutting problems then you know what that
means everybody watch the other
understand in some places the attendance
was quite dismal how it was Christmas
pointed out you know new attendance were
worth was quite high bear in mind the
population there if we had dined hundred
people at the Bailey meeting we will
regard invest quite a success what's
going to send the population of Bailey
free person and population of loyalty go
you know so we managed it worth the
response back has been open things over
200 responses which is probably quite
have to be going with now if we had ten
times people responding in 10 times the
comments and we had two thousand
comments link i think the obviously
struggling now go back to the comments 0
200 well I just wanted the way they list
it and in public arts me now look taken
to abandon number 51 about stream
reductions colleagues can be passed on
to Essex I always has it been passed on
and number 16 which was about King ever
install capacity calm acknowledging them
will be clear it has it been quit so I
think the thing even if you want the
poverty to take these conversation
seriously we have to follow things up
even though I know that the work
involved the future consultations I'm
gonna be meteor because issues an option
to document I think 13 h ones being a
like tops document they even so we're
getting closer to the more serious
business sector
the whole system and people be more
interested and they will go on if they
think was something worth going on for
what we did they launched in the last
client watch this to somatic slumber
directly he mentioned the plan and but
in very great opportunity tell you in
the document it matters what were
planning tale for your area think of a
close if you look if you want to and
people just ignored it till really an
anything out and writing it needs to be
more specific to the area none of our
turbulence point about it being a
district-wide spatial document people
naturally I want to be more interested
in their area and it won't respond you
were talking about that their area
that's really just one last thing you
said so about some people respond to the
end of consultations is that what
happened with this consultation I have
to pass over yeah you could get quite
high volume towards their like the close
of the concentration so regardless is
alerting spin so if we're doing that
they were looking up an intense
consultation and the level is not very
high we can look at the graph from last
time and see where we will be and in the
case of where we are that will help yeah
and I'm thinking need to stop take into
account the fact that in the next stage
people actually gonna have something to
physically to rate though it's going to
take it's going to take on them to read
that and then to portray the responses
and Smith to us so yeah as a as Matthew
koinonia there is generally ain't I'm
dad but I mean in terms of wondering
what happens at any of any events that
we don't for example then we can
certainly certainly do that but the
intention of the next time around
have something firmly in place before we
start concentration so people know
exactly when any events are going to be
what's taking place when okay I would
still want to see a complete line of
perspectives war schon welcome on
numbers if right here I think we said
what it may be as well in fact in a
domestic that for this summer can the
glass get a question here chris has
raised a couple of points they are is
there any mileage or will they
subsequently come out in more recent
correspondence that we get from various
bodies the points that will chris is
just raised is there any managing and
picking these out and sending a round
robin to these various bodies and saying
comments please I suppose if you can go
after them or you can go first if you
listen to me the statement made by
county about the number of in the plan
the schools about I can't visit 304
secondary area whatever and the two
schools in the two developers one in
rochford and money ready that meant to
be provided as part of development
answering the primary concerns of albeit
they won't necessarily be in the right
places where people live at need access
to local schools but the issue around
secondary schools it's a big one and it
is a huge one frustrating and with all
the
and children locally to that but that
information is already out there from
county isn't it so you know Jim there
will be there has been the statements
around how they're going to address
those numbers but how that's actually
going to happen in detail within the
schools that we know have no space to
capacity to enlarge as in secondary
schools on their current process is very
sorry especially on the point of passing
on issues we have started to soar any
fruit so for example at the raelia
meeting whether residents have been
proposal for construction traffic that
we passed that on already so we are
working away still through through the
issues our primary focus was to to have
something to bring to this meeting to to
show you what that what the outcome was
but we also work on the quick wins if
you like well we can try and make a
difference on that in the short time
where we can and and on your point
concern i'm about education and we have
had a couple of meetings with and with
essex county council and we this was a
particularly after the aquarium workshop
where there was a big concern about
secular education
and and we said well we need to know
exactly what current position it needs
to at least go to the end of our current
plan period we need to know what
position is and we need something
clearly sets out how they work together
to determine what our future leaders as
well so we should have some sort of
statement if you like which should be
ready scale with issues and options next
year because you were coming yes just a
very quick observation as to where we
were looking at the just get this
absolutely right where the early
engagement consultation statement if you
want you to look on page eight I thought
there's a very interesting of telling
item in there well earthquake and
holdrege believe in a hot way which I
know can be a very potent area at times
I had known nearly 1,500 people were
notified of that meeting 1503 only 40
turned up now that's less than three
percent of those people 95 now we've got
an area there or people who are
interested and then even more telling is
hullbridge we have nearly a thousand
people who were notified directly
notified by five letter and email and
get only 47 turned up and I would have
built home it would have been even
bigger attendance than they actually
showed so you did there is an enormous
amount of
thing out there it seems i'm proud to
comment on this chair okay that's it
let's go systematically pissed off with
john and then we work our way down but
you know I think we've already
highlighted at the pound point and we
we've already made our point as to what
we what we hoped would happen in future
for consultations and a bigger more
robust notification system to all
residents I agree we can't drag people
to these meetings I would hope because
as my colleagues here and said there is
a more structured statement coming out
in future this is what you can actually
look at rather an open-ended scenario
that there will be more interest but I
take your point Ian but that you can't
drag people there and yes they were
notified but perhaps when there is
something more concrete on the table you
might get more positive responses job
well if we go start voting figures if
you look at page 9 you look a whole
Grove 291 invitations were what were
solicited and the response was over ten
percent yeah now I'm going to take a bit
of credit for that and like Kristen
because obviously I sought to publicize
it people do listen I'm going to refute
and I'm sorry to say your view that this
apathy on planning issues I don't think
that's the right word and I certainly
wouldn't agree or subscribe to that I've
spoken before it's about it's about how
we engage with people and the way we
interest them in the subject to you know
stimulate their interest
in responding which is it is important I
know Chris spoke about what healing I
mean I've got an email list and it's
quite it's quite considerable it's been
built up over a long period of time of
representation and I use that facebook
page and my own or our own website if
you like and I know looking around the
room there was a lot of people ville I
knew I knew them personally and I knew
that they would have received some sort
of invitation for myself sometimes you
know it's about responding to the
individual and trusting the individual
and I said it was important and I think
they turned out so I don't think it's
apathy I think it's about how you engage
well I think we we can spend all day
yeah arguing about interpretation of
wording generally if you got something
different to to to go on that number
will globe you Cody I'm going the
operatic yeah I think we I say I think I
think we just offense floods once I'm
death of the main we know we know what
to make I was just appalled the only
comment I was going to make was maybe we
should look at the message that were
actually putting out and the copy that's
used and the comms team should be split
test in how we put out the message to
areas as well maybe one area doesn't
read as the same message as another area
and that's something we can put with
combs to discuss this happens with
different age groups example the way
that you approach our younger I don't
know if if we all geared up and this is
something personal you can have a
chamblee comes about whether we are
geared up as a council to deal break
things down that specific I don't know a
guy it might not be difficult but
they're not here to discuss yes it's
something we can concern me talk about
um aren't you is there anything you want
you to come in anywhere
you said originally about not getting
counselors particularly town council to
attend because it wasn't a consultation
or workshop for counselors it was for
the public and one or two comments that
I've had from from in mobile and being
from one or two people that did attend
i'm not sure if it was both at the same
workshop and i think it was was that it
was all councillors and then verse that
were there was busy talking to the one
or two minutes they probably did that's
specifically to one or two members of
the public that didn't turn up and not
engaging with everyone that was there
that you could turn that around and say
well that's up to them they should have
made sure that they had engagement but
and the public or sometimes a bit
reticent to push themselves forward when
you're on too many councillors singers
dominating the situation and I think
that is something well we're all used to
be talking in public being in a public
forum some people aren't than their game
yeah III don't know doing I mean that
some of the ones that I went to I mean
we specifically I can recall a hotly
specifically went round and spoke to
people sat down with little to no
speaking back yeah but oh yes in
relation to the attendance aralia and I
think price is right most people in
rainy don't see the developments in Wes
Raley as
any problem no I'm it's not going to
affect us yeah we've got um Center the
pollution that you know to traffic he's
going to be a problem but it but it's
not in our it's worth it it was
basically raley's built up there's not
many places left is you're quite right
you little thing a majority with the
majority of the rest of Riley there
isn't room to develop any murder it's
already your applications in it's
already being developed it there is no
area to that comes when tracking pliers
our place and either adequate medical
what about school issues school places
in surgery doctors at the NHS provision
all of that we've become an issue for
everyone but the other issues were about
that second workshop was really really
last minute many of us 12 we found the
one who's my friend was very low turnout
jus tryna past nine in the morning
what's a particularly very good time to
people we found that it probably around
people out more where they wanted an
evening session when they couldn't be an
evening session so what the residents
were tending to turn round and say was
it was done so people couldn't come
along to find out what is actually going
on the roof district councils mmm oh
[ __ ] I couldn't be in more of an evening
rather than a data on my own and Ian
they pointed out was a very good
salesman if you want do pops you want
new roads have more houses built up some
comment that we kept coming back oh yeah
I am but I think I don't I think this is
one of the things that you will never
win I mean the best imported events were
during the day doesn't matter how you
try and Dalia up and I think again it's
something we've learned from and we will
bear this in mind when we go down
we will have to take this in it is a
learning curve before we progress
anything further hopefully we'll have
another meeting before we start going
down the road again and we can Matt and
cocoa and come up with some plans or
some ideas but I can appreciate that
they have problems getting responses
from some parishes and in the end it was
a Hobson's choice you either have it now
all or you don't don't understand why
they could have a choice by 4p but we
couldn't get contact with the parishes
become get an answer from you could get
contact with Sharon cuz shams in contact
with well always parachute you couldn't
we did have some fun and games no all of
them but I won't be mad do you wanna
come yeah I was just saying um you know
evening day meetings done lots of
different ones and it can just very
massively you know you can never predict
what's going to happen you know during
the joint error action plan to quote
that again you know an indie that was
interesting lots and lots of people I
did a number of evening meetings where
you know it varied from 50 people
turning up to two people over the whole
night you know and that's just various
different places throughout throughout
throughout south end at the time because
I was doing on about half of it so and
they were evening meetings and it was
well-publicized you know their posters
papers news jeff needs droppings
everything we thought we could possibly
do we had done but you couldn't predict
i was sit up sitting there on my own for
two hours you know sort of just waiting
for people to come in but they didn't
come so it can be very unpredictable i
guess yeah it is because we've got so
many new developments going on in white
cream people don't like the idea of
having a morning one where they can't
put their point of view across when
they're working they wanted to be there
in the evening mm-hmm i guess you know
that that's the debate of daytime
evening meeting some people can't make
evening so they like to sort of come in
the daytime you know they prefer to come
out in the daytime so it's very
difficult to predict for different areas
and and satisfying everyone is very
difficult you know that
once they've been better off if an
evening one would it be flagged well
from the date so much okay it also has
appreciated thank you Jim I just got to
point out that when it was talking about
empathy it has been in the past that oh
well the council do what the council do
and our views are not respected as
residents and not taken into account now
we are trying to of this side of the
fence if you like whichever you are
called it all the whole of us are trying
to change that around in as much as we
want you to get involved and this is
what IAM aside about getting involved
and getting the views of the residents
then we must make sure that we are
putting in to our policies to our
planning what those views are we must it
absolutely make sure because in the past
it's been well they do what they want to
do they don't take no notes of us and to
prove the point is that instant and I've
asked mr. scrump and my strengths on the
same question is that we need to go out
there to find out the truth of what is
being spoken to us whether it's coming
from an authority or not an authority
there are other avenues to take views
from and we are not taking those views
of one particularly concerned about is
the the small if you like flood forum
which has been which government of term
owners said that we should take views of
them as well as everybody else and which
we are not doing so on my point is that
we need to get we need to make sure that
the residents views are paramount
interest whatever we think you've got to
make the point of differential here
there are certain bits of legislation
that irrespective of what the public
view is the government's view or the
planning authorities may be in conflict
with
now we can register our thinking quite
rightly says in here when we do our
options that where possible residents
views will be incorporated right early
on in in the planning application I mean
that's what we will try to do that's why
we're having this yes if that there will
be areas up until you now where you and
me may think we should do something on
planning authorities will save no and
there will be areas like that we all
know that but it is quite clearly stated
in there that we will where possible
take residence views into into
consideration in future plan gone well I
mean that's you know planning is that
difficult budget isn't it you know it's
that balance between the environmental
social economic you know it's a
difficult one and it's finding that
right balance because lots of people
have lots of different views and it's
how you bring that together in a plan I
suppose you know residents views are
taken into account and that's the
terminology that the government used
throughout the process of putting a plan
together but equally the authority has
to make sure that the plan is based on
sound evidence so it has to be sound
evidence it has to be robust evidence
that takes those policies forward as the
plan is formulated you know we take thee
into account the views of statutory
professional bodies as you've mentioned
and flood list as one of those and the
EA is that statutory body we also take
into account the views and opinions as
you save residents or you know if a
local flood risk for mum put in their
views they would be taken into account
during that process but when we get to
the examination process and this is a
process set by central government this
is the process that we have to follow to
get those plans adopted so they
prescribe a formula which has to be you
know a roundtable discussion and
examination in public now those who may
have objecting views to a plan they can
put in their views and can be asked to
sit and sit on that planning roundtable
that hearing session and
put their views and evidence and across
and if they feel that they have
justified and robust evidence to the
contrary of what is in a plan they can
get the planning inspector who sits
there independently to to modify that
policy or that proposal based on that
sound evidence but it has to be sound
evidence that we follow so just just
just to know the course that it has to
go through to get to that stage so it is
an independent planning inspector who
makes that final decision on the plan
it's not the local authority it's not
the you know the public and it's not
statutory bodies it is that planning
inspector but that planning inspector
has to make their decision based on
absolute sound evidence nothing else
it's nice to hear from you that you are
going to listen to other bodies other
other than the authority of bodies that
we do listen to at the moment and it's
welcome those or welcome that you've
you've done that all of them to ask you
to do they need that respect is to
invite them to find out who they are and
to invite them rather than they invite
their selves it would be nice for our DC
to invite them to to anything that may
that would be of concern to them and one
is that so yeah you know either bunny
sure that everybody knows who everybody
knows you yes remove oh I'm talking
about and and they have not been asked
as other councils in the England should
I say a puts their something forward to
them and we are we off but I don't know
you ask them particularly you know st.
particularly why marina to join the
other day well I'm not going to go into
this anymore but I'm just saying let us
open air let's open their doors let us
bring in these other well I love Susan
kress I think think think everybody i
think i think it's been my quite clear
that we were in go
as best we can with all relevant bodies
to make sure we get all the best I mean
is all our homes it's all our area yep
we will do the best we can on behalf of
our residents to ensure their engage
with the scenario be that their views
are taken and where possible we will
incorporate their ideas that have used
and everything else in future plans for
the district but there will be areas but
with the best will in the world ignorant
I mean we're not going to be successful
I think members we've had given item 5
are pretty pretty lengthy airing there
is a recommendation on section height
which says that proposed that the site
committee recommends the council that
the content at the early engagement
program consultation statement are set
out in Appendix A be agreed John like to
move an amendment as around decatur yeah
I spoke earlier they are whether I'll
get a second room are advised to replace
the word agreed we'd noted yeah for the
reasons that i stated which was simply
that i recognized what the residents
would have would have said but the
responses i cannot agree the move I
can't breathe so I prefer to stay noted
okay that your home in but i'm not going
before Jim get okay and if you look at
saying that that will be the the view of
the committee okay
okay thank you very much for that
everything on to section or item number
six is that you again Leslie yes yeah
and so as per the previous two
subcommittees and just set our food
outline of what we've been working on
over at all over lost amongst the
philosophy and what I planning for for
the next sixty five month and so as you
will see we've been we put up don't be
involved in the cost point counsel local
plan examination at the momen and that's
off the back of the comments that we
submitted earlier in the year half a
submission stage so we will be involved
at the formal hearing chatter on 12
December and we will continue to be
involved in that until the inspector
makes his decision and also also being
involved in the southern Essex draft
white craft waste local clan which is
also examination and the robot war
councils will have received an email
from me recently to notify them that
there's an additional site at donovans
farm that's been the inspectors
recommended is include included in the
plan but that's going to be subject to
further consultation next year and don't
have any one
Christie wants to sell thank you on both
points and driving class some point one
of the what is our district councils
main concerns without a casa point plan
our main concerns are that console point
hasn't filled the legal quad with the
duty to cooperate and and of the back
that it hasn't produced a sound plan
which should be adopted by casa point
the the main concern is that the change
between the 2014 preferred options and
2016 pre-submission isn't isn't based on
sound evidence and it's what they
basically done with you if you've had a
chance to regain our response them that
we submitted they use they produce a
certain plan in in 2014 where they could
meet basically that they could
comfortably me a certain number of homes
per year their motive decision in march
26 game which there's like no longer
accommodate that they can only
accommodate half that amount and that's
not based on sound evidence they under
the duty to cooperate they haven't we
don't feel that they've had rent in
discussions with the neighboring
authorities on what what's going to
happen with any unmet need and so and
that that's something that's that view
is shared across generally across South
ethics as well because because they've
produced that plan it has wider
implications for from neighboring
authorities under the dutiful break do
you want to elaborate just add to that
just to show that we're not allowed in
our thinking as nothing said all other
South Essex authorities have put in
similar objections to Castle points plan
but it's not just our housing sub region
that has it it's beyond that there's
about 12 or 15 objections from
neighboring authorities in relation to
their plan under the duty to cooperate
so it is it is not just rotted who who's
of that opinion just so you know John so
Chris yeah I'm second point regarding
Dunham's far could you elaborate amount
of people are members because I think a
lot of counselors interesting that hi
and as finally could you let me also of
what consultations will take close yep
and and how it impacts on existing
council plan which has been notorious
code proposals really hitting the waist
high dimension as far okay and so as a
result be the examination that went on
last last month into the waste local
plan the council was recommended that a
specific site for basically landfill at
donovans farms is included within the
panel which might be found and to meet
the county's and waste needs and wasn't
included for in the previous version of
plan which is why we haven't weren't
actively involved in it there's only
general policies which rendered to us in
terms of civic amenity centers for
example since I at donovans farm and
partly in rock traditions and partly
batted in boro so what the what the
county council ends up in Borough
Council or looking to do is have a
members briefing on a third of January
for more members to basically go through
what the implications of allocating that
side would be and that's then going to
be followed by a public concentration on
so they called proposed modifications to
the plan so any these are modifications
that the inspector is recommended which
would materially change the plan which
will submit it in government and so it
will have Donovan's farm in there as an
additional allocation for a waste
disposal as well as a number of other
fundamental changes to to the plan which
is inspector things that need to be made
in order to make the plan sound that's
due to start on the fourth of July
believe yeah we don't know the exact
details yet all we know is that we've
been notified by the bias County Council
that there is this different proposal
which would have implications for the
Busby Rochford just yeah just a Delvian
statutory at least six week consultation
person yeah yeah similar to what we've
done previous they were after we've had
a hearing session so it's generally just
the table of where and key changes is
likely to be made
okay you would ever happen to be
selections with it obviously there is a
certain amount of recycling and that's
what the county councils taking account
of obviously there are other types of
waste which can't be recycled which need
to actually there's also part of the
whiners plan of the the white yeah the
plan basically has a hierarchy of how
you deal with waste so and this i think
then feel i'm not sure if it's I think
it's in a waste so you know that
basically the developer and their agent
put forward at the roundtable discussion
so this is you know they were invited to
comfort for their point across and they
had an area of land that was you know
below landline levels so they argued
they said there's a waste capacity gap
existing for Essex and south end and
they said we can help meet that need and
we feel that there's still a need for
this so they convince with their
argument the inspector to allow this
site to go into the plan however as it
hasn't been consulted on it now has a
statutory at least six weeks
consultation period for that to occur so
Rochford and other authorities can put
in their thoughts on whether this site
should be included so because obviously
it wasn't included at the pre-submission
stage but yes there is a waste hierarchy
but it has been identified that there is
a need for this site as far as the plan
is concerned Christian sorry John you
were next man yeah turn on I've got
quite a few observations and questions
about so okay yeah I've done hopefully
that colleagues take an answer them but
if they can't but then they'll just have
to start so we actually here the first
one is I I notice and abroad and agree
that we need to find a better way of
working with Essex County Council on
highway infrastructure issues because we
know from the you know the early
consultation statement but that is one
of the highest issues on residents minds
and I know
others minds I think there are some
roads that you missed not in that
particular analysis but I think that
could become evident anyway but I think
the point and the request i'm making
it's a request presumably we're engaging
with a tisket a council on how we would
like to see them engage with us and give
us the sort of understanding and
evidence that we can use sensibly to
take a view our spatial planning
analysis that we can actually feel that
we can own and that can be owned by
residents and members so my request is
I'd like to see that come back to this
this sub sub committee so that we can
see how that is going because I think
it's so Michael then if we miss the
opportunity to engage with that our
resumes we'll all probably ask why we
didn't think of how we should exercise
ourselves in policy so I hope that
something you can agree to what we're
doing at the moment we're working with
them as County Council and their
partners with my Jacobs on reducing the
complete baseline report of where the
the hot spots are across the district
i'm working at the the network as a
whole and trying to I mean we know where
they are but it's useful to have a
formal report which identifies where
those hospitals are where the where the
key challenges are as well and that that
will be we ready in time to be published
along side the issue
options and off the back that will for
my baseline then we'll look at the next
stages will look at the more detailed
modeling at any mitigation measures that
we can the week look at realistically in
the district can that come to this sub
committee before it goes into the issues
and options I don't want to be ambushed
by residents in particular i SPECT you
know it's it's a it's a technical
evidence-based document but yes you know
it can be viewed by the by the community
you know it it would like any piece of
evidence we're presented with the
evidence and that's their view and
opinion even if it's not in its final
Thea market yeah if we have a I como I'd
like at the very least in the aligning
policy subcommittee to look at evidence
even if we're not going to expose
evidence legal counsel and for Council
debate that we might wish to recommend
that inappropriate places here and at
least i think this subcommittee i'll do
it okay yeah i think i think it's good
so that everyone in the subcommittee
because it's a planning sub-committee is
aware of the evidence base that's coming
forward those elegant okay but second
question is about and I don't know what
you call this I'll probably try in
number of ways of saying it shayla I've
got a mouth speaking in tongues yeah nah
I'm now drunk the question is I know it
was going to be coming out soon and I
don't know it's before the end of the
year oh just after the project plan will
tell me that but is that going to invite
comments and observations from residence
or is it simply going to be this is what
we think stop I mean this is another
evidence-based document so from how I
have treated them in the past and how
authorities I've worked out of treating
them in the past this is another sort of
piece of evidence base that helps form
what goes into a Nisshin operative
issues an option stage of the local plan
so it is not a consultation document for
residents as such in the same way that a
strategic flood risk assessment is or
retail
style is so it's a piece of evidence
that informs the local plan and
residents will then comment on the local
plan asylum should let me challenge out
a little bit if I'm a front perspective
that you helped me get which is always
useful and we spoke about we know that
an analysis I think I know the analysis
of each site in the call for science is
the basis of sustainability looking at
environmental socioeconomic factors or
ones that we can comment on as
counselors without impinging on planning
probity so if I if I read your
deposition in the shower should I
whatever you call it and I don't think
is right how do i or ii need anyone else
feedback to the council and challenge it
what I guess is if that site comes
forward as part of the issues and
options local plan so if that site is
including the site for employment
residential mixed use Industrial
whatever it is if you don't feel that it
is deliverable justified you know you
can comment on that plan at that stage
and say say you know I don't think that
site is going to come forward I don't
think that's the right use for that site
with evidence then absolutely fine you
know help me win they're going to
incorporate it into what and when so if
a site comes forward from from the call
for sites and is put into the issues and
options stage of the local plan say for
instance those sites once they're in
there or whatever stage they come in to
the local plan they will then be open
for consultation and then it's open for
others to challenge whether a site
should be part of the plan or not but as
I say it can't just be I don't like that
site it can't be it hasn't to be you
know justified and that's you know
that's for us we have to justify through
evidence what we do and those who are
challenging us because when it gets to
the examination process
as I say with the planning inspector
that's what he's going to be looking for
okay yeah I don't be sorry good yeah
don't say looks like to point out that
the cheater she don't remember that the
Internet in Spacedock mean it doesn't
allocate land there is clear guidance on
the in the planning practice guidance on
how we treat those sites so we make sure
that we treat them equally and there's
no credit prejudice with regard to those
sites and so that's the approach that
we're taking with that so it is a
they're not funding policy yeah not
they're not allocated so I'm not
climbing it until they come in to I tell
you why the race because we're talking
about engagement are we yeah you know
we're talking about really interest
residence I tell you what really
interests residence is where and
potentially further developments in what
a nice or will take lightly that's which
is why I raised it because you know as a
certain amount of frustration get a
creepy and if we don't we don't explain
to them when they can give say what they
think whether it's some supporting
evidence or what I said you understand
where you're coming from and when we
when we do publishes the issues not
because it would obviously look at how
we deliver any housing and so look at
and what a strategies go in today so
people may at that point wish to comment
on specific size we can't stop people
commenting on specific size but they
can't directly challenged the evidence
if if you like they think or we can
click into that evidence directly they
can go and it really that's really
applying I've got it nothing's bad
nothing is really changing except you
know um this is now what a wider
understanding of that issue okay i'm
still not currently going I've got
relevant things honestly an action group
in in billericay commented to me that
the brexit slaw or the implications of
breck see Amish ma are unlikely to see
it's unlikely to be published by the end
of the year as
project plan shows they weren't looking
to a project plan I'm looking at how
project plan and they're talking about
maybe June that's not they like
information that we can get on yeah just
to give you a bit bit background we're
also producing as you will have read and
South ethics wide couldn't Edna [ __ ]
initially arose five-year economic where
the needs assessment and they're looking
to the consultants are looking to align
the underlyings or demographic and
economic work so there's been a bit of a
hold up with the chamar work but the
latest information we had is that they
should be published in mind they decided
on what economic forecasts that we
should go ahead as a sub region so now
that that work can go ahead yeah so
we're still expecting about it being
good clarification thanks man and I come
to counsel point I take it we're going
to be represented on the 12 in december
will then we'll put photo able to be
going i'm happy to attend just are very
in the insertion it is an open section
so as per the hearing sessions we've had
before you have certain around the table
who have been honestly invited but then
people went to the public whoever can
observe they call me so here's a public
you know totally for real yeah but a
private mother units it's it the
inspector invites who they wish to give
evidence fine so you so you you and
Natalie young good so I think it's
important you there because yeah I think
there's going to be some interesting
challenges it will be an interesting
because I then a carseat castle point is
rolling over somehow because you know I
find myself in a very difficult position
because we've got you've got residence
in Castle Point who were contacting me
as a representative of residents group
of July saying you really do support you
know our our stance and our strategy on
the numbers of houses and saving
greenbelt don't you
and I'm kind of thinking well no because
this unmet need and you're very close to
how something I don't think John you're
going to find rocks with district or any
of the other no bring districts rolling
over either no okay I just put I'm men
they were ok then the other thing that
starts to me in a response we we state
that castle point hasn't engaged with us
okay so we have a duty to cooperate as
well and although that interface may not
have worked even though we may have
tried can you tell me what we've done
with regard to the other councils that
we need to interface with and at what
point will be reached a memorandum of
understanding and beyond that do you
want to start yes so we directly excited
tree yes so as officers we have regular
monthly meetings to discuss strategic
issues housing of course is one of those
our main issue is that there hasn't been
a specific discussion on cost a point
because there at that say John what what
happens now effectively and they paint
okay a decision they've got down a
specific route but they haven't
considered what the implication well the
wider implications are of that for naval
authorities and so although we we do
meet on a regular basis there hasn't
been that detailed level of engagement
between the authorities to our
satisfaction that we can we can say okay
we aren't clearly understand where
you're coming from and this is what as a
sub-region we're going to do about that
many show you that hasn't taken place
and we've also got a south essex members
group
which me on an on an ad hoc basis at the
moment and is also a head of service
group that meets order on a regular
basis as well so there is that level of
engagement that has been ongoing at self
as its level but the specific cost point
issue hasn't been addressed as yet you
haven't completed the whole questioners
math you can do but I'll cause I also
value a memorandum understanding yes as
I understand it part of the duty to
cooperate statue yeah we have to
exchange those formerly with other
County it's something that the council's
have developed together as part of the
do to cooperate officer group through
the heads of service group and then and
then to the members group that's still a
work in progress at the moment this
memorandum understanding but in the
background of Natalie said the
authorities have cooperated on strategic
issues however housing has been one that
has been more difficult to reach any
conclusions on yet and the twelfth of
December is going to be sort of quite
influential in moving that forward
because we are going to have a planning
inspector who will make a decision at
the end of those hearings and he may
suggest how the authorities move forward
as far as talking about housing delivery
in south essex I mean interestingly this
you know castle point are in the
position they are because they
progressed quickly with with a plan but
as naturally said they may have not
considered that housing to the full
degree even if they had considered other
strategic issues along the way
potentially Baz erdem could be in a
similar situation as well so you know
this isn't just a decision that's going
to affect cost the point it's going to
affect buzzer lands position as far as
their plan is concerned and then how we
all come together from that moment to
discuss you know the pertinent issue of
housing because you know that's that's
the one sticking point as far as the
duty matters are concerned and I think
that's why the inspector has decided to
hold just a one-day hearing because
normally you know this is normal
the first day of a local plan hearing
you know you do the duty you do the
legal compliance and soundness then you
move on to all the individual issues but
they they just arranged one day one
session because i think it's going to
sort of come to the fore about how the
authorities move forward with housing in
the future so after the 12 we should
know a lot more presumably you're doing
a briefing paper for members yeah we can
post thing as i bought yeah we can do a
briefing paper post area but only
obviously once we have the decision of
the inspector of them young lady right
promise you chairman my very last point
and i have a struggle with the
recommendation again and i'm going to
explain to you why the particular issue
I have is there were the addition of the
water words subjective resource
constraints because I can't put my name
to that because I don't know what the
resource constraints are they've not
been evaluated and I'm not being given
the opportunity to consider how they
could be managed or mitigated so
therefore if I that goes forward to for
counseling then I will not be able to
answer the question as to pour voir they
have you evaluated them how you gonna
manage so if I can't do that I can't
agree to the recommendation I want but
if you're prepared to take those words
out which I don't think add anything to
it anyway because everything is subject
to resource constraints and then I can
support it but it's it's up to the
subcommittee to consider the matter
okay too disappointed when i read back
the worst min because as you say well
before we get to that I think james you
were on the list hood I am chairman
heaven so funny i need to declare an
interest in the poly ones item as a
tenant of SJ phone I just wanted a quick
question to Natalie and will that
invitation be extended to non for
members about the sand oversight because
I think that yeah does happen in other
areas potentially I mean yeah I mean um
it'sit's in ischia range wasn't it for
basildon counselors asked or yeah no
invitation to be sent out wasn't and
then say invited and you suggested that
long for counselors in that ward all the
other 10 can we go back to Essex waste
planning team just just to find out what
what level of resources they have
available and then come back to on that
one today is that ok just to see just to
find much just to finalize what format
they've got it in what size of facility
and then we can see what's available but
we could come back to you later stay on
that first okay okay the same question
yes I think it's nicer than just yeah
okay any Christian yeah Thank You Jerry
just to try and I'm gonna put the
spending to work so he look like it but
the depression in Donovan's farm was can
what is looked at in the way of the
flood alleviation that as you know that
could be a way of pushing the water over
to Donovan's farm as that's quite a big
green belt and it's planned and what
have you you with the depressions that
there are over there they'd hold an
awful lot of water from what I
understand n and there was there is an
overall view if you like in the planning
of that utilizing that ground so and I'm
really worried about the waste that will
be put there and where it will drain off
to as it will join off to into the brook
which is a big concern at Roy I've got
bring that into your attention so and
then short County will be positively you
know about me I mean that something but
you know could be raised as part of the
consultation depending on what kind of
waste it might be a nerd waste it might
just be soil or whatever you know going
into that area but dependent of that we
can raise those points anyway I mean
isolation either join offices yet and
rain off and we're lumping or win and
there is all some thought of some of the
football active or activities whether it
be football or wiping is going to be a
transferred over up to diamonds farm
which is another concern as a health
hazard if he's going to be I didn't
realize it was going to be obviously a
waste a filter to refill I thought it
was going to be just a transfer station
yeah I know it's only thunder but we've
gotta look at me because I'm sure I'm
sure the site I mean you motorpoint yeah
3 i'm sure other bodies cool thing yeah
be fully employed developments it can be
raised in free essex and suffolk yes
okay unless there's any other issues or
comet remembers you wish to make
it seems fairly obvious and vice and
Sonia this is only down to this
committee as the wording here so that
can't work streams continue can we take
out subject to ya result constraints
okay three yes Kenny yeah thank you yeah
I mean okie astray item 6.1 does point
that out quite succinctly anywhere yeah
so okay unless there's anything else
members I'll close the meeting at eleven
thirty six okay thank you very much
[Music]